[Musique]
on le vole pas tout de suite pas trop ne
soit pas si pressés nous nous refait
jamais ma tante jeux qui vont être
contents hop hop hop hop hop hop au bon
soir les enfants vous aussi vous allez
être contents car nounours vous a
réservé une surprise
bonsoir mes [ __ ]
chicala t'apporter la suite de
l'histoire de filippi oui je vais vous
la raconter allons je me pose
là
où on tue on nous
dit c'est beau allons nous promener dans
les bois bryas
il fait beau allons nous promener dans
les bois
propose à la maman de philippines à sa
petite fille
des cas une
philippine mis sur sa tête la casquette
de son papa pris un saut une pelle un
râteau un petit panier avec du pain pour
les oiseaux et suivi sa maman
avec son temps pour arriver dans la
forêt la maman s'assied au bord du
chemin sur atteint les philippines sur
un autre talus et se mit à émietter sont
pas pour les oiseaux
quand tout à coup elle vit dans laird
tout près d'elle
[Musique]
restée moi oui une fraise des bois tout
en rouge puis une autre et mais pas
notre affaire philippines en mangeant
quelques unes puits rempli son petit
panier de toutes les fraises qu'elle
trouve à la dernière sa maman le petit
panier était plein de frère
lorsque
diby dit tu pizza pizza le lapin blanc
arrive en courant et mange à toutes les
preuves
lapin attend crise et filippi mais le
lapin blanc se sauva bien vite
alors philippines très en colère se mit
à taper sur son tambour de toutes ses
forces
les oiseaux se mirent à piailler très
fort et le preneur
prenant très fort
dit plein philippines et sa maman
rentrèrent bien vite à la maison tout ou
des lins moment à l'humain pot au feu de
bois dans la cheminée pour se sécher
attend lapin attend continuer à répéter
la petite philippine
pour lui faire oublier ce garnement de
l'apa blanc
[Musique]
je ne m'en rappelle plus j'ai encore
oublié d'apporter la suite salle hors
taxe d'un genre que jacques rouquette
antilles je vous la porterez la
prochaine fois ce produit et je vous
laisse le lit
vous êtes content
merci mais ça nous fait 3 yves allons
les enfants
animaux non admis
boloni députés
là c'est un liner
fait pour
[Musique]
elle était très jolie ton histoire
nounours nicolas et pimprenelle lompo
coupable mais j'ai de nouveau oublié la
suite pas trop on y va en route bonne
nuit les enfants allez vite vous couchez
embrasse bien fort vos parents il fait 2
pour 1
oh
[Musique]
e
m
[Musique]